[Music]
i keep thinking how special it is that
we're standing here in the crockett seam
the place that dad loved
more than anywhere else feeding crocs
and spending time together as a family
it's hard knowing that she'll never get
to actually meet him
and it's it's devastating because i'll
never get to watch that connection
but i cannot wait to be able to tell
beautiful grace all of these stories
about dad to be able to share with her
what an amazing father he was
and um
it's um yeah it's gonna be
it's gonna be really special it's gonna
be really special for her to um
to know him yeah through us
[Music]
to tell her about what an amazing man he
was
and it's um gosh
it is really hard it's hard that he's
not here
because out of um everyone in the world
gosh he would have loved her
the most he would have loved her so much
but i think in a way he is still with us
and
his his heart and soul lives on in all
of us
and so yeah he's never really gone
crikey it's a baby exclusively on
discovery plus
streaming april 25th
you